evolution we've been we've been doing
our own genetic engineering through
through breeding over time it's taken
much longer now we can go immediately
and start tweaking we can eradicate
disease we can do augmentations to
humans which are do you have a specific
kind of favorite that you're most
interested in in the space well so the
the most powerful preventive medicine
which is also augmentation that that we
should all be familiar with is we should
be constantly celebrating his vaccines
we have about a couple dozen vaccines
that make a superhuman relative to our
ancestors they they lived in fear of you
know a smallpox of polio of many
diseases that we now have
we're not fearful of because they're
either completely extinct nearly extinct
or completely controlled by the
vaccination process that in principle
some of that could there could be
similar things that happen that increase
our health over our lifetime that could
be gene therapies for example it could
reverse aging as we get older there
could be some that have cognitive
advantages as we get older so that we
prevent a cognitive decline in a
population that's rapidly becoming kind
of lopsided on the on the older end of
this of the demographic spectrum we
could have you know cognitive
enhancement to reduce that cognitive
decline and and who knows where we go
from there but those are examples of
things where genetics is not
fundamentally different from drugs
except the connections between mechanism
and therapy is so much more direct and
faster and so we we need to they'll go
through the normal vetting processes of
safety and efficacy through the FDA the
EMA C FDA and so forth